meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
liebe familienangehörige freunde und
verwandte wir haben uns heute versammelt
um zu trauern allerdings auf um sie
nicht zu vergessen unsere gehirnzellen
[Musik]
mittlerweile schon vierten teil dieser
serie ja ihr könnt das wahrscheinlich
schon erahnen was heute spielen
herzlich willkommen hier in meinem raum
in die wiese ist hier die so sind wie so
kommt wie so hallo das ist mein zuhause
keine ahnung warum mir so viele mädels
chillen aber es sind halt alles meine
zeit schickte ich habe keinen plan warum
mir wieder so eine party ist bei mir in
der bude und sie selbst verschwindet ja
okay dann gehe ich mal raus ich ja nicht
dass eine wohnung hier also das hier ist
mein wohnzimmer im jahr kommt packt das
motorrad aus alle hässlichen raus ja da
kannst du direkt bei anfangen aber erst
mal alle die hier neu sind eventuell bei
der serie movistar planet mit luca oder
vielleicht doch komplett neu auf meinem
kanal ich empfehle euch direkt wieder zu
gehen denn mein content wird euch echt
eure gehirnzellen kosten wenn wir schon
bei meinem garten vorbei hier ist
niemand
wenigstens hier habe ich meine ruhe ein
paar sekunden später als lahm
natürlich kommt alles kommt alles vorbei
war movistar planet geht es darum dass
ich dieser hässliche typen wir haben
übrigens eine neue krone wären auch
hasen oder mittlerweile und wir haben
neue frische eisbär schuhe petionville
ähnliche schreiben wir doch jetzt mal
anhalt bin großer filmburg auf 10 4 also
ich habe diese billy elliot 090 jetzt
einfach mal angehauen von wegen auf die
bankette ein foto zu machen
ihr status ist hey mein status ist ich
stinke nach aber wir passen super
zusammen eigentlich als ob du luca bist
ich will ganz normal hier mit williams
090 schreiben und alle fragen jetzt
irgendwie ob ich hier luca bin also wir
gehen mal wieder raus aus dem café im
dass dies allerdings
meine damen und herren haltet euch fest
mir hat jemand diese hängen ja ich bin
jetzt was besseres als alle anderen
heißt ich kann jetzt bei den chaträumen
unter anderem hier in den vip club gehen
das heißt wir kriegen einfach mal oh
yeah yeah we the people
da haben wir jetzt erstmal ein paar
dance moves raus auf bitte oder er ist
ein sonderbar scans like this ich darf
tanzen wie ich will grüne raupe
abgehoben ich muss einfach mal weinstadt
wird klar machen ich kann nur sagen ich
will ich will dir im miami vip flotte
wird sagen wir ziehen uns dieses mal mvp
club so cool ist das ja auch nicht gehen
mein haustier paar ich brauche immer
noch einen scheiß haustier
also schauen wir uns einfach mal um ich
würde sagen ich kaufe den hier
der sieht aus wie so norbert finde ich
also dass hier unten ist jetzt mein haus
hier
dieses kleine dinge ich bin jetzt auf
jeden fall im haustierpark hier ist okay
wir sind auch ein paar lockeren drachen
schorn kussi ja sein nachname ist
anscheinend gucci und maine usa mit dem
sollte ich mich vielleicht an freunde
schon gut ski
wie schon kannst du reden
hier geht's wohl irgendwas los das heißt
ich würde sagen wir gehen mal wieder
rüber in meinen raum also hier zählen
jetzt auf jeden fall ein paar leute die
glaube ich vermehrt zuschauer von mir
sind
das heißt ich begrüße jetzt einfach mal
ganz freundlich ganz nett sympathisch
also wirklich ich meine es ist ja schön
dass ihr in meinem raum sache stinkt
alle krass nach dampfendem parker ich
find's einfach wichtig dass man seiner
community gegenüber mit respekt entgegen
dritteln von daher schauen wir uns jetzt
mal die reaktion von denen hier an
toastbrot apfel mit elefanten kacke ich
bin eine wunderschöne kartoffel ich bin
cool du stuhl ich bin ein pudding
bärchen was lade ich für eine scheiße
rung ich glaube das problem mit
elefanten bei movistar planet ist
mittlerweile einfach dass jeder dieses
outfit kennt von daher brauchen wir mal
so ein bisschen style veränderungen 2000
jahre später da so wirklich keiner
erkennen so schleppen wir jetzt erstmal
hier zum skatepark m und hauen mal die
star rot weiß an
ich suche ja immer noch eine freundin
movies hat leider das heißt ich schicke
jetzt erstmal eine freundschaftsanfrage
und schreibt ihr jetzt schreibt man
jemanden wenn man die namen date fra muc
auf pommes rotweiß gedacht wenn die es
da rot weiß heißt dazwischen auch pommes
rot weiß die junge garde waiting
angeheuert
so will keiner mit mir schreiben ich
schaue jetzt einfach noch mal im café
hier vorbei hier sind ja eigentlich
immer ganz coole leute das hat die
letzten mal auch immer ganz gut geklappt
habe mit leuten zu chatten also ich habe
jetzt einfach mal die alia 57 an und ich
tue jetzt so als welche teil jener
romantische dinner romantischer
italiener
baidu ein hässliches stück elefanten
scheiße bist a hallo der stadt ich das
heute wieder jetzt auch beenden wenn
euch wie bereits gesagt das video hier
gefallen hat das unbedingt einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da schreibt
wir uns in die kommentare ob ich nächste
woche teil 5 von mobistar planet
hochladen soll abonniert main kanal
damit ihr das nicht verpasst und jetzt
kommt das outro
[Musik]